everybody welcome to another exciting
episode of The Gadget Lab podcast I am
Roberto Baldwin and I'm Alexandra Chang
first off we're gonna talk about Windows
Phones right tell us a little bit about
their selling them now they're their
pricing what's going on definitely not
selling them yet that's for sure but
basically Nokia today really saw this
pricing and availability dates for the
Nokia Lumia 920 and 820 which it
announced earlier this month and those
are the two flagship windows phone 8
devices coming from Nokia this year and
what they've done is released European
pricing and what we've learned from the
European pricing is that these phones
are expensive and that means Windows
Phone 8 has another drawback to it
because now they're competing against
well-known phones like the iphone right
you samsung galaxy whatever they're like
15 of those so what we've seen is that
the 920 is probably when it costs around
800 u.s. dollars on chambers
unsubsidized no no to your contractor or
whatever and these are European prices
so this is like conversion rates and
everything but that puts it at more
expensive in the Samsung s3 and around
the same as the iPhone 5 us prices
unsubsidized are definitely going to be
lower and with a two year contract
that'll mean you know even cheaper so
we're thinking it's going to cost around
the same as the iPhone 5 and galaxy s3
in the US on US carriers which is
unfortunate for windows phone because
Samsung Galaxy X 3 and the iphone or
boast big names everybody knows about
these phones everybody knows about their
operating systems whereas windows phone
is still trying to kind of break through
get out a fourth place and so windows
phone is behind rim at this point they
have freedom yeah around three percent
market share which is kind of a little
bit sad and I think that they
acknowledge that it's sad today as in
Microsoft so they're hoping that Windows
Phone 8 will change those numbers and
like sort of you know get more adoption
but the fact that these phones are going
to cost the same
as phones that everybody loves and knows
is sort of hard to imagine consumers
being like yeah I'm going to go with the
windows phone when I can spend the same
amount of money and get an iphone yeah
it's gonna be a tough sell right they're
gonna have to do a lot of marketing and
that's pretty much it for the Windows
Phone news these are going to be
available in November so they'll still
they'll be here in time for the holiday
season so in ereader news the kindle
paperwhite we finally got our hands on
one of these puppies they are available
beginning october first actually will be
shipped october first right now if you
try to order one october twenty second
because everybody's buying these things
but this is the brand-new paperwhite
this is amazon's answer to do to the
nook glowlight so what do you think
compared to the nut compared to the nook
just the screen itself the the contrast
the lighting it's better it's Amazon's
really put a lot of work into making
this a great looking screen you know the
adjustments for the for the lighting are
pretty exciting you can do this all day
it's a much better capacitive touch
screen than the old kindle touch now
something that's cool it kindle has done
is they've even out the light for the
most part it's evenly distributed better
than the inductive no need to kind of
see lines and so all the lights are on
the bottom instead of the top which the
nook has lights on top so while you're
reading it if you read it at an angle
you're going to see these lights and
according to amazon that's going to
cause fatiguing great but you can't see
the lights down here at the bottom that
is that is one of the things they're
they're they're a bit more faint than on
the nook color or the nut glow light and
something that you probably you can't
see on film but something i really like
is the texture of the of the actual
screen it the texture itself is really
nice it smooth oh it's got like a nice
like rough like almost like a hard card
stunt like feel to it so it's much
different where this which is a little
slick um so who should be buying this
device right there okay if you read a
night in any way and you were tired of
lugging that kindle fire or an ipad or
whatever into bed with you this is a
pretty sweet deal it's a really nice
book it's it's a really nice ereader i
wish it had buttons for you know it's
still the sort of i'm a big fan of
buttons on my e-reader zai touching the
screen means when i do this to pick up
the e-reader I'm accidentally going to
the wrong page but it's pretty lie it's
pretty thin you know if your ereader fan
like myself this is kind of a no-brainer
great so you'd say that's probably the
best e-reader on the market now yes I
haven't been able to get my hands on the
Kobo okay they have a new light up at
you reader glowing ereader I've got my
hands on it so I can't totally say that
it's the best on the market but it's the
best one I've used and I was a huge fan
of the nook with glowlight and I think
this one it looks better the lights are
much nicer and as far as we know amazon
probably has the best ecosystem so oh
yeah that terms of books and in terms of
books come everything if you're part of
that ecosystem if your prime if your
amazon prime then this is a no breaks
you get free books you can read you can
borrow and that sort of thing so if you
have an e-reader and you don't read at
night you don't really care you can
still stick around with the old one I
mean I still have the old and that one
costs this one now they're calling it
and they're calling it the $69 06 our
kindle this is actually did the previous
version this isn't that the brand new
one to 1600 hours but it's basically the
exact same kindle you can check out the
full review it's on the gadget lab now
right now so as soon as videos over just
click it around five six seven times
until you find it okay oh that's it for
today that is it thanks for watching and
we'll be back next week with another
exciting episode of The Gadget Lab
podcast